jeff bezos gets a lot of slack for being
an unethical businessman
from the seemingly monstrous working
conditions within amazon
and their very low tax obligation to
amazon's monopolistic position within
the market
and jeff bezos massive fortune at first
glance
it does seem like bezos is a nefarious
slave driver
but is this actually true
[Music]
well starting off let's take a look at
labor exploitation
this is one of the largest criticisms
jeff bezos receives
but here are some of the things that we
should keep in mind
just a few months ago over the summer
amazon reached a total
of 1 million employees now
i understand that the working conditions
for these people
is a hotly contested topic but at the
same time though
i think most of y'all would agree that
having a crappy job
is much better than not having a job at
all
and i think it's pretty safe to assume
that amazon
has given a million people at least some
sort of respectable job
which has been especially important
throughout the pandemic
where tens of millions of people
couldn't even get a job at all
i thought that was important to address
as creating massive amounts of
non-illicit jobs itself
is arguably a good thing despite the
drawbacks
also if we take a look at pay well
amazon
is actually ahead of the curve as they
raised the minimum wage
for all of their us employees to 15
dollars per hour
over two years ago conversely other
large employers such as mcdonald's
and walmart who boast over a million
employees each as well
still lag behind at 9 to 11 dollars per
hour
and as for other logistics companies
well
the starting wage at ups was just
upgraded
to 14.50 on august 1st 2020
and the average starting wage at fedex
is approximately 14 to 19 dollars per
hour
so amazon is in line with other
logistics providers
and is actually quite a bit ahead of
other employers with
over a million employees i'm not
claiming that the pay at amazon is
justified
or even that it's good i'm simply trying
to point out that
employers of similar size actually pay
less on average
and other logistics companies pay about
the same
so it's not like the wage at amazon is
surprisingly low for the industry
or anything like that in fact linkedin
who has over 722 million profiles
worldwide
so plenty of data to pull from ranked
amazon as the third
best place to work in the us and they're
only beaten by google
and facebook they were especially ranked
high due to their minimum wage
of 15 dollars per hour and their
expansion of 401k plans
as a result putting aside anecdotal
evidence
there is no objective evidence
suggesting that amazon
is a low paying employer per se however
that doesn't mean that amazon is good
all around
though i don't agree that amazon is a
notoriously low paying employer like we
are often told
they are no doubt a monopoly jeff bezos
generally frames a question of monopoly
within the context of sectors
aside from e-commerce for instance he
may point out that
amazon is competing with google and
apple in the smart speaker space
and that amazon is competing with fedex
ups
and usps within the logistics space or
he might even say that amazon is
competing with walmart
target and best buy in the retail space
but while these are true we all know
that their real monopoly lies within the
e-commerce space
amazon controls nearly half of the
e-commerce space within the us
at 49 that itself shows that amazon
is a monopoly but this would be slightly
better if second place came in at 20
or 30 percent however second place
is actually ebay and they come in at a
mere 6.6
on top of this 9 out of 10 consumers
price check products
on amazon before buying and 95 million
people in the us alone
have amazon prime subscriptions thus
jeff bezos
does run a monopoly and this is
absolutely an unethical aspect of jeff
bezos
on the bright side all monopolies do
eventually fall
as their monopolies are crushed by
innovation
next up we have social responsibility
amazon
isn't related to the energy or oil
industry
so they're mostly able to avoid concerns
about environmental pollution
sure their trucks vans and planes put
out co2
but it's not even comparable to energy
and oil companies
moreover amazon has already announced
that they will start using electric
delivery vans
produced by rivien starting next year so
it's clear that amazon is well aware of
their environmental impact
and they are constantly working on
improving this
but social responsibility is not just
limited to environmental impact
another large portion of one social
responsibility would be philanthropy
now i'd like to preface this by saying
that jeff bezos
did create amazon and all the wealth
that he has accumulated
is his own thus he has no obligation to
give
any of it away at the same time though
from a moral perspective
when one has more than they need the
right thing to do
would be sharing some of their excess
wealth jeff bezos
has given away a few billion dollars
which is no scoffable amount
but it does peel in comparison to other
billionaires in this league
like bill gates mark zuckerberg and
warren buffett
who have all pledged 99 of their wealth
to charity
so that's the current state of bezos
philanthropic work
finally the last major portion of a
person's social responsibility
would be pushing society forward in one
way or another
and with billionaires these are
generally large projects
for example bill gates has been set on
vaccinating africa
and elon musk has been set on colonizing
mars and helping a transition
into electric vehicles in this realm
jeff bezos
actually does have a pretty large scale
idea which
is off-planet manufacturing and energy
production
i have a full video on his plan to do
this if you're interested
but in essence he wants to use a space
company blue origin
to move heavy polluting industries into
space and
other planets it's really quite a
revolutionary idea
and he would help society at large if
you were to succeed at this endeavor
anyways moving away from social
responsibility we have
economic responsibility and the media
often heavily criticizes jeff bezos
as well as amazon for not paying their
fair share
of taxes though the media always points
out amazon's small tax bill they rarely
point out
that amazon barely makes money in the
first place
amazon's retail business was actually
not even profitable
until 2018 meaning that they lost money
for
24 years before making a penny
these excessive losses were the reason
that they didn't pay any taxes
in 2018 so it's not like they were
making billions
and just somehow wrote it all off rather
they had lost money for a quarter of a
century
so they were able to cash in on a tax
break for one year
since then they have started to make
billions of dollars
and now they pay billions of dollars in
taxes
if we take a look at their q2 earnings
report we'll see
that in the 12-month period ending on
june 30th 2020
their income before income taxes was
9.604 billion
it should also be noted that their net
sales during the same time period
was 164 billion meaning that their
profit margin
is less than six percent so really not
bad
anyways they ended up paying 1.729
billion dollars in income taxes
which as a proportion of their income is
a solid 18 percent
and considering that the corporate tax
rate in america
is 21 amazon really isn't writing off
that much
of their income aside from this it
should also be pointed out that they
invested 35
billion dollars in the same time period
into building warehouses
the equipment to be put in warehouses
acquisitions etc
with all of that being said i do believe
that amazon
does fulfill their economic
responsibility sure
they may have not paid any income tax in
a given year
but they also employ over a million
people
invest tens of billions into our economy
on an annual basis
and are now paying billions of dollars
in taxes given that they're
actually profiting billions and finally
that brings us into the point that jeff
bezos makes tens of billions of dollars
per year
while his employees earn meager wages
i've pointed this out several times in
the past
but this is not a case of amazon paying
basis billions
while ripping off the average employee
in fact
jeff bezos only makes a modest eighty
one thousand
eight hundred forty dollars and he earns
zero stock compensation
the other 1.6 million you see here is
spent on various security expenses for
jeff bezos
which is also very little for the ceo
and founder
of a trillion dollar company if you take
a quick glance at the ceos of other top
tech companies
you'll see a stark contrast in ceo
compensation
sunder piche of google makes 281 million
dollars per year
tim cook of apple makes 125 million
and elon musk receives billions per year
in stock compensation from tesla alone
considering this jeff bezos is actually
one of the oddball ceos
who receive no stock compensation and
all of his wealth gains
come from the amazon stake he originally
owned which
he has been consistently diluting over
the past several years
when i pointed this out in the past
there were some people who commented
that if that's the case
jeff bezos and other executives should
be forced to liquidate their shares
to pay employees better which i really
don't get
at all the employees at amazon
knew what the pay would be before
joining and they joined without force
from amazon
so i'm not quite sure why jeff bezos as
well as other investors
should liquidate their shares to pay
even more anyways
personally i believe that jeff bezos and
amazon
are net positive socially and
economically
however it is true that they are a
monopoly
but at the end of the day if you don't
like jeff bezos business practices
then just don't buy from them if enough
people
agree with your views amazon will see a
decline in the revenue
and they will make change but that's
just what i think
how do you guys feel about the ethics of
jeff bezos comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys appreciate
the depth of his analysis
and consider joining our discord to
suggest future video ideas
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one